велика подорож маленького будиночка так
званого тайні Хаус його розмістять у
Ганновері на півночі Німеччини на
задньому дворі житлового будинку що
належить комунальному і
житлово-будівельному товариству
транспортні витрати 10 тисяч євро цей
тайні хаос виготовили в Естонії чотири з
них розмістили тут ціна будиночка 75
тисяч євро в одному з них живе банкір
Даніель Вайс Я зрозумів що насправді
почуваюся комфортніше в таких маленьких
приміщеннях ізбагнув що тут я так би
мовити більш міська людина і проблеми що
в місті дотепер Не було жодних житлових
проєктів
пральна мінімашина з 30 м² використано
кожен сантиметр вишуканий мінімалізм
ажіотаж на такі квартири величезний
брали участь 150 претендентів даніелю
навіть довелося провести презентацію
PowerPoint перш ніж його обрали серед
інших претендентів тепер він жартує
коти відіграли вирішальну роль
[музика]
загалом по всій Німеччині гостро
бракують житла
спершу були високі ціни на нерухомість а
потім знову зростання відсоткових ставок
навіть людям з великими доходами важко
дозволити собі будинок за нинішньої
ситуації
ті хто більш-менш заробляє раніше могли
дозволити собі такі односімейні будинки
але нині вони в дефіциті і дорогі за
останні 10 років ціна зросла вдвічі до
400 тисяч євро і більше столяр ульф
трюфель та його партнерка побачило у
цьому ринкову нішу Вони виготовляють
маленькі будиночки коли тайні Хаус
готовий його доставляють у клієнтам
автобану такі будиночки з'явилися вже по
всій Німеччині ульф та Діана також
живуть в одному з таких поселень але
крихітні будиночки схвалені владою
переважно лише в кемпінгових поселеннях
причина багато Мері не бажають визнавати
цей новий тип житла будинками та
забороняють їх у своїх селах це дратує
власників
це завжди Можливо на колесах чи не на
колесах незалежно від того ми також
будуємо його з колесами чи без них Чому
я маю впиратися в те що формат цього
села червоні дахи зелені дахи чи щось
таке Це повна нісенітниця
зовсім поруч крихітний будинок його
партнерки вона була першою клієнткою і
замовляли У нього сьогодні вони і пара і
сусіди у кожного Свій маленький
будиночок
гадаю Це добре що ви можете просто бути
разом якщо захочете але можна також
просто зачинити двері і сказати Окей
сьогодні один вечір Я побуду в себе
вдома ситуація з дефіцитами житла у
Німеччині ще більше загострилося торік
коли у ФРН прибуло Понад мільйон
біженців з України це створило додаткові
замовлення для виробників таких
будиночків як приміром для цієї компанії
у східній Німеччині
її керівник Маріо 2 вже звів шість таких
будинків
чотири з них призначені виключно для
сімей біженців
це іде у 0 штат гольштейн тут є чотири
інших
їх також незабаром відправлять там
розмістять український біженців А коли
вони поїдуть додому Я думаю що ці
будиночки потрібно використовувати для
відпочивальників
тут на півночі Німеччини вони вже є
маленький будиночки для українських
біженців ними опікуються Голова місцевої
соціальної установи цей пристрій
перекладач допомагає йому спілкуватися з
ними Я записала свого сина до школи йому
там дуже-дуже подобається
ситуація дуже напружена на ринку житла
майже не залишилося квартири з огляду на
це ми придбали ці будиночки з іншого
боку ми не можемо купити нове житло для
кожного біженця який приїде
цій жінці пощастило В чотирьох Її родина
живе в цьому новому крихітому будиночку
є спальня для сина та невістки і ще одна
для батьків мерія заплатила за цей
будинок 90 тисяч євро українці яні
довелося покинути своє невеличке
господарство в Україні разом з нею
приїхав її син та чоловік родина жила в
селі під Маріуполем нині ця територія
окупована Росією
[музика]
хочеш закрути мене все життя було
щасливим Ми навіть не уявляли які ми
щасливі багаті люди до
24 лютого 2022 року коли прийшла у наш
дім війна першими ми побачили колони
російської техніки військових з
автоматами Було дуже страшно Ми з дітьми
сиділи у підвалі
маленькими сусідськими дітьми
її новий будинок маленький але красивий
я назбирається пожити тут певний час але
після війни хоче обов'язково повернутися
в Україну